the violent protests in Minneapolis over
the death of a black man who appeared to
be suffocated during an attempted arrest
officers in riot gear fired tear gas
while protesters threw rocks and chanted
I can't breathe echoing what 46 year old
George Floyd that's his name told police
before he died repeatedly Monday night
the photos from the scene show people
using milk to wash the tear gas from
their faces
George Floyd's arrest can be seen on a
ten-minute video it shows a white
officer using his knee to pin down
Floyd's neck four officers have been
fired for this incident and the city's
mayor says quote being black in America
should not be a death sentence Jeff the
gaze is in Minneapolis forest where he
spoke to members of Floyd's family Jeff
good morning you also saw last night's
protest what were they like yeah well
they were peaceful to start but they
quickly escalated into violence behind
me you can see the growing memorial to
George Florida it's right next to that
bus stop where that cell phone camera
captured his arrest and the last moments
of his life about that protest they were
right here at the scene where the arrest
occurred but as they started moving
downtown the crowd started getting rowdy
as they got closer to the police
precinct where they believe the fired
four officers worked
this was the chaotic scene in downtown
Minneapolis last night
[Applause]
hundreds of protestors clashing with
police over the death of George Floyd
tear gas and smoke filled the air with
some officers using rubber bullets to
break up the growing crowd earlier in
the evening chance for justice rang out
at the site where Floyd was killed the
protests followed Ford's death on Monday
night a white police officer pressed his
knee and to Floyd's neck for more than
seven minutes as the 46 year old pleaded
for help with his hands cuffed behind
his back before his body went still last
night we spoke to Rodney and felonies
Floyd George's brothers and Tara Brown
his cousin you don't believe when they
say that he was resisting and that's
what sort of got the strain of what they
say you can see what you saw and I saw
the petrous on every person in America
saying police claimed Floyd was a
suspect in a forgery case at a deli and
that he had physically resisted officers
but new surveillance video obtained by
CBS News from a restaurant nearby shows
officers calmly detaining him attorney
Benjamin Crump is representing Floyd's
family he was handcuffed long before
they took him to that car and you can
see his demeanor from the security video
they did not have to use this excessive
lethal force that kill George flowing
they did not have to do it and that's
why simply terminating them is not
enough because black lives matter we
need to see justice happen in this case
this was clearly murder we want to see
them arrested we want to see them
charged we want to see them convicted
for what they did he did not deserve
what happened to him
I don't want the protests to just be for
show I want to see action I want to see
these people pay for what they did we
need to hold them accountable I see you
wiping tears from your eyes what's
running through your mind right now when
you're you know just going through this
just thinking like how amazing my
brother was he never did anything to
nobody everybody loved my brother I just
don't understand why people want to hurt
people kill people they didn't have to
do that to my brother he can't breathe
he can't breathe
nobody don't want to hear it we took a
look at the Minneapolis police training
manual and it says that neck restraints
are only allowed if a suspect is
resisting an officer's actions and it is
only allowed as a non deadly hold if
it's not restricting an airway and so a
team of local and federal prosecutors
will have to decide if the officer's
actions here on Monday were justified
for a criminal prosecution Gale it's
still Jeff very difficult to look at
that tape I think one of the things
that's so upsetting is that it can an
encounter a black man's encounter with
police can go from zero to death in a
nanosecond I think that's what so on
everybody's mind when we look at that
video but I'm curious about the actions
of the mayor there you know he was
clearly upset during that news
conference how unusual is it that action
is taken so quickly that when I heard
the news that the officers had been
fired in the afternoon normally there's
an investigation we have to look at the
tapes we have to interview witnesses how
unusual is this to happen this way well
you know we've done a lot of work on
this and it's it's fair to say that the
city took swift action here but the
reality is post Ferguson a lot has
changed in policing and what they have
learned is that in situations like these
where you have this cellphone video as
dramatic and as troubling as it is you
have to
take action or else it could lead to
unrest in a community and so when you
saw the police department move quickly
to fire the officers involved and the
mayor's statement these are lessons that
have been learned post Ferguson Gale
alright Jeff thank you very much George
Floyd's death has brought an outpouring
of support for him across the country in
Chicago protesters marched to express
their outrage chance the rapper helped
organize that event and other well-known
figures spoke out on social media
presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee Joe Biden tweeted that Floyd's
family deserves justice and called for
police to be quote held responsible for
their egregious actions on Instagram
former NBA player Stephen Jackson
remembered a longtime friend who he
considered to be family law was my
brother man we called each other twin
brother everybody know me and fluoride
called each other twin my boy was doing
what he's supposed to do man y'all go
and kill my brother Stephen Jackson said
he was heading to Minnesota to do
whatever he could do to help